was können wir uns noch erhoffen für
diese wahl ich kann ihnen sagen was ich
hoffe hauptsache wir kriegen nicht
direkt die nächste große bitte nicht
ehrlich jetzt wirklich noch eine groko
dass heidi nicht aus das land braucht
endlich wieder unterscheidbare
volksparteien den wettstreit der ideen
letzten dienstag da hat sich der jetzige
bundestag zum letzten mal getroffen und
tatsächlich hatte die stimmung so ein
bisschen was von sechste stunde
entsprechend genervt die lehrerin jetzt
möchte ich nur noch kurz darauf
hinweisen wenn meine zeit auch so gut
wie vorbei ist dass wir da haben meine
redezeit hier das ist ja mein gott ich
setze euch gleich auseinander
die schieber frau dr merkel aber ich
habe mich auch gefragt wen wählen müsste
ich denn jetzt eigentlich auf sicher
wählen um die nächste gruppe garantiert
zu verhindern
ach du scheiße und löhne der mini makro
wirklich jetzt übrigens jeder sieht gut
aus den schwarz weiß nur mal so am rande
aber kann man diese neue fdp den jetzt
wieder guten gewissens wählen ich habe
ja gehört die hätten sich völlig neu
erfunden
was sind denn die neuen themen der fts
sind letzten endes auch themen die wir
in der vergangenheit schon hatten aber
es sind themen die stärke in die
strukturen reingehen mit einer mit einem
neuen auftritt den wir auch optisch
umsetzen wollen durch frische und farben
wir versuchen vieles im glas meist nicht
so wichtig so wichtig ist auch wieder
nicht gut wenn man das neue fdp programm
wenn man das programm jetzt regelrecht
ließ das neue dann ist es natürlich im
wesentlichen das alte sozialstaat teuer
eigenverantwortung geil und im focus
fordert lindner nach der weißes
steuersenkung aber halt jetzt andere
farben muss auch mal reichen und
vielmehr auf englisch habe ich
festgestellt zum beispiel heißt
bürokratieabbau bei denen jetzt wann
sony prinzip
und nicht nur das und dann ist da noch
das man im prinzip ebenfalls
bürokratieabbau
one in trub prinzip was ist das 1 1 1
raus bin ich
j
das macht doch sinn das gute alte rein
raus spielt wenn man damit keine stimmen
fängt weiß ich es auch nicht
und wer weiß noch lachen wir wer weiß
vielleicht kriegen wir ein paar wochen
jamaika fdp mit union und grünen das
wäre dann also nicht eigenverantwortlich
ist kiffen dass man von der steuer
absetzen kann
und von wegen die fdp ist nur noch ein
mann partei
nein nein der macht inzwischen sogar
eine frau mit die alexa alexa
freidemokraten bildung wir wollen die
ganze welt beste bildung stärken
alexa warum ist politik kompliziert wenn
es auch einfach geht ich mir nicht
sicher
wir schon alexa wieso kommt eine partei
die 2013 völlig zurecht und viel zu spät
aus dem bundestag geflogen ist jetzt mit
dem gleichen neoliberalen scheiß wieder
rein
keine ahnung du vollidiot gibt es doch
gar nicht so aber seien aber dankbar
voll digital die fdp war sei mal ein
bisschen dankbar dieser kampf um den
dritten platz der ist allerdings noch
spannend wer holt bronze
die fdp die linken die grünen oder oder
doch die afd
mit solchen slogans hier hole dir dein
land zurück gemeint ist wahrscheinlich
elsass lothringen ich jedenfalls nein
ich jedenfalls habe mir für die
heute-show saison die jetzt beginnt
vorgenommen mich viel weniger über die
aufzuregen ehrlich es ist auch so
wahnsinnig ermüden diese immer gleiche
auf dem asche letzten dienstag auch
schon wieder hier alice weibel verlässt
unter gejohle marietta slomka studio 3
nanosekunden später kommt schon eine
vorformulierte pressemitteilung in der
die af der umwelt wie ungerecht weil ein
staatsvolk behandelt wird allemann folge
bei zu mir und dann setzt ihr
pressesprecher ein gewisser markus
frohnmeyer noch einen oben drauf und
twittert an die kollegin marietta slomka
zitat am 24.09 mach ich dich arbeitslos
mäuschen
süß oder er meint das ernst am 25
september also einen tag nach dem
endsieg wird der rundfunk von frohnmeyer
persönlich gleichgeschaltet und dann
kann die kleine slomka aber höchstens
noch bei lidl die regale einräumen das
mäuschen schon gespannt was ich dir afg
für mich überlegt und ja auch dieser
sexistische kotzbrocken frohnmeyer sitzt
demnächst für uns im bundestag sofort
eine neue haltung ist das muss man alles
aushalten wirklich alles wenn zum
beispiel dieser opa gauland über unsere
integrationsbeauftragte frau usus sagt
wir werden sie dann auch gott sei dank
in anatolien sorgen können dann schlug
ich kurz das halb verdaut runter und
sagen wir nein oliver aus wir wollten
noch nicht mehr mitmachen
bei diesen billigen trick weil sie keine
echte lösung für irgendwas haben müssen
sie über provokationen im gespräch
bleiben das alles da steht bei denen
sogar im strategiepapier ab jetzt ohne
mich und dazu jetzt kommt meine damen
und herren empfehle ich ihnen dringend
unsere neue heute-show entspannungs cd
diese hier ja lasst die arschlöcher noch
lagern
das ist eine entspannungs cd bei uns im
heute-show fanshop drauf sind
hauptsächlich reden von bernd hocke aber
jetzt kommt mit walgesängen unterlegt
[Musik]
die angsträume werden größer in unserem
land gerade für blonde frauen super
auftritt des fdp-politikers während
röcke in herford mein name ist jörg
[Musik]
jetzt geht es mir schon besser oder ist
das schön der bern